let's get some practice calculating
interquartile ranges and I've taken some
exercises from the Khan Academy
exercises here and I'm going to solve it
on my scratch pad the following data
points represent the number of animal
crackers in each kid's lunch box sort
the data from least to greatest and then
find the interquartile range of the data
set and I encourage you to do this
before I take a shot at it all right so
let's first sort it if we were actually
doing this on the Khan Academy exercise
you could just drag these you could just
click and drag these numbers around to
sort them but I'll just do it by hand so
let's see the lowest number here looks
like it's a 4 so I've had that 4 and
then I have another 4 and then I have
another 4 and let's see are there any
fives no fives but there is a 6 so then
there's a 6 and then there's a 7 there
doesn't seem to be an 8 or a 9 but then
we get to a 10 and then we get to 11 12
no 13 but then we get 14 and then
finally we have a 15 so the first thing
we want to do is figure out the median
here so the median is the middle number
I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 numbers so
there's going to be just one middle
number I have an odd number of numbers
here it's going to be the number that
has 4 to the left and 4 to the right and
that middle number the median is going
to be 10 notice I have 4 to the left and
4 to the right and the interquartile
range is all about figuring out the
difference between the middle of the
first half and the middle of the second
half it's a measure of spread how far
apart all of these data points are and
so let's figure out the middle of the
first half so we're going to ignore the
median here and just look at these these
first four numbers and so out of these
first four numbers I have since I have
only have an even number of numbers I'm
going to calculate the median using the
middle two numbers so I'm going to look
at the middle two numbers here I'm going
to take their average so the average of
4 and 6 halfway between 4 & 6 is 5 where
you can say 4 plus 6 is 4 plus 6 is
equal to 10 but then I want to divide
that by 2
so this is going to be equal to 5 so the
middle of the first half is 5
you can imagine it right over there and
in the middle of the second half I would
have to do the same thing I have four
numbers I'm going to look at the middle
two numbers the middle two numbers are
12 and 14 the average of 12 and 14 is
going to be 13 is going to be 13 if you
took 12 plus 14 over 2 that's going to
be 26 over 2 which is equal to 13 but an
easier way for numbers like this you say
Li 13 is right exactly halfway between
12 and 14 so there you have it I have
the middle of the first half this 5 I
have the middle of the second half 13 to
calculate the interquartile range I just
have to find the difference between
these two things
so the interquartile range for this
first example is going to be 13 minus 5
the middle of the second half minus the
middle of the first half which is going
to be equal to 8 let's do some more of
these this is strangely fun find the
interquartile range of the data and the
dot plot below songs on each album in
Shane's collection and so let's see
what's going on here and then like
always encourage you to take a shot at
it so this is just representing the data
in a different way but we could write
this again as an ordered list so let's
do that we have one we have one song or
we have we have one album with 7 songs I
guess you could say so we have a 7 we
have two albums with 9 9 songs so we
have two nines let me write those we
have two nines then we have three tens
cross those out so 10 10 10 then we have
an 11 we have an 11 we have 2 12 to 12
and then finally we have so use those
already and then we have an album with
14 songs 14 so all I did here is I wrote
this data like this so we could see okay
this album has 7 songs I sell them as 9
this album has 9 and the way I wrote it
it's already in order so I can
immediately get get I can immediately
start calculating the median let's see I
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten numbers I have an even
number of number
so to calculate the median I would have
to look at the middle two numbers so the
middle two numbers look like it's these
two tens here because I have four to the
left of them and then four to the right
of them and so since I'm calculating the
median using two numbers it's going to
be halfway between them it's going to be
the average of these two numbers well
the average of 10 and n is just going to
be 10 so the median is going to be 10
median is going to be 10 and in the case
like this where I calculated the median
using the middle two numbers I can now
include this left hand in the first half
and I can include this right 10 in the
second half so let's do that so the
first half is going to be those five
numbers and then the second half is
going to be these five numbers and it
makes sense because I'm literally
looking at first half it's going to be
five number second half is going to be
five numbers if I had a true middle
number like the previous example then we
ignore that when we look at the first
and second half or at least that's the
the way that that we're doing it in
these examples but what's the mid what's
the median of this first half if we look
at these five numbers well if you have
five numbers you have an odd number of
numbers you're going to have one middle
number and it's going to be the one that
has two on either sides this has two to
the left and it has two to the right so
the median of the first half the middle
of the first half is 9 right over here
and the middle of the second half I have
one two three four five numbers and this
12 is right in the middle you have two
to the left and two to the right so the
median of the second half is 12
interquartile range is just going to be
the median of the second half 12 minus
the median of the first half nine which
is going to be equal to three so if I
was doing this on the actual exercise I
would fill out a 3 right over there